would you have produced cartoons of the
type published by shali Abdo well the
chances are I would not have but that
doesn't mean that they shouldn't have
been published nor should that the
cartoons lies been put at risk for doing
so you know this is a conversation that
we've been having for a decade since the
you know Danish cartoonist first
appeared and it's an interesting one I'm
glad we're discussing it now why
wouldn't you have done they were just
like that yourself well you know
whenever you do cartoons
you're being very conscientious about
the audience that you're trying to reach
and the point you're trying to make and
this is many different cartoonists as
there are comedians as there are
musicians then you have all different
kinds of perspectives and and approaches
to their work and with my audiences with
both the economist and the Baltimore Sun
it's a they they wouldn't necessarily
respond well to these type of cartoons
and I try to do cartoons that in my
world is not racist or sexist that's you
know what I would like to do but and I
look at other cartoons that I don't
necessarily agree with and many of them
let's say I don't even like but I still
think that they should have the right to
be able to be published mister
difference between cartoons which
comment perhaps savagely and cartoons
which set out to offend
I think obviously that's in the eye of
the beholder to some extent but I
suppose my concern really is with the
politicization of these deaths to some
extent so that actually this the murder
of these people these journalists and
two police officers and now more police
officers in the wake in fact is is a
national tragedy but it's one that's
being instrumentalized through a sort of
binary construction between free speech
on one side and sort of offended Muslims
on the other and the concern there
really is that that plays into the hands
of the very extremists who set out on
this mission I suspect that their
objective once wasn't so much to target
free speech as we're hearing so much I
mean I think they said that they had
avenged the Prophet of course and I'm
not suggesting that that wasn't part of
the motivation but I think if we're
looking at the background of some of the
jihadis that does suggest that they've
got links to broader international
networks that are trying to sow division
within listen within European societies
in order to recruit Muslims by
suggesting that they don't have a place
in Europe that
conditions in Europe and becoming
intolerable from the Slim's and in doing
so in fact this attack actually plays
right into the hands of the far-right
they would have known that they would
have known that that would have led to
national discussions which would have
been placing ever greater pressure on
Muslims and this is something we're
hearing from French Muslims their fear
that actually this is going to end up
polarizing society even further than it
has been no more Jesus do you think
that's true do you think it is going to
be harder to be a Muslim in France as a
result of what's happened well yes
actually I'm not afraid about terrorism
I'm afraid about the consequences on the
society and yes I feel that I feel that
a lot of tension I hope it's just a
feeling and it's not true but I can feel
that and by being a comedian is not
about if doing a joke or not doing a
joke is why are you doing this joke or
why are you not doing this joke and if
the reason you're not doing this job is
fear it's the bad reason we are here
we're standing for freedom like
everybody and it's not about Arabs or
Islam absolutely not it's about
craziness and this this is it did you
find yourself running craziness no more
today did you personally like Charlie
Hebdo do you find it funny well I don't
find all the jobs funny of course as a
Muslim I don't find this drawing
especially relevant maybe but as a gay
can be I'm not offended by a joke it's
not possible to be offended by a joke in
my point of view but maybe I don't like
them I don't find them funny and that's
it and that's it
it's not a question about you have to do
in it or not this is it I got friends
were for Charlie Hebdo and I'm okay with
that the tower will only choke this is
only comedy and catalyst if a joke
doesn't work it doesn't mean it's you
have in fact you haven't already
it's the main purpose of a cartoon
political cartoon to be funny to be
amusing what what do you set out to do
when you draw a cartoon well you know
when you're an editorial cartoonist you
live within two polarities you know
editorial which is serious cartoon that
is funny and then everyday you kind of
plot yourself within different part of
that spectrum according to the
appropriateness of the subject matter
and your own personal style and taste
I'd like to say that political cartoon
is really our colonists on the whole
they're using pictures and humor to you
get a point that's usually what we're
trying to do not get a laugh that's sort
of topical humor rather than say you
know a satire but why what are the
things I wanted to mention is that you
know whenever we do a cartoon every
single cartoon we do take somebody off
because we're dealing with ridicule and
and and caricature and it's always that
someone's expense and if we're in the
business of worrying all the time about
who were offending we just have to stop
drawing ma'am one way you want to what
function do you think magazines like
Charlie Hebdo serve well actually
historically Charlie Hebdo served a
really great function it spoke truth to
power which is ideally what you'd want
the press to be doing but I think oh you
know for him to quote Olivia Sahar who's
a former Shari Abdul employee he himself
said that post 9/11 Charlie Hebdo had
taken a racist turn that he actually
himself objected to some of the images
that they were using because he himself
felt that it was contributing to a
broader climate of anti-muslim hatred in
France and so he would object to that
himself I would say that there were some
images of Charlie Hebdo today who
continued to take the traditional stance
of speaking truth to power there is some
great character in there but there is
also some much darker undertone to some
of the images which really need
questioning and have been questioned
prior to this events racist undertones
which have to be called out and should
be called out but of course are never
ever going to be an excuse for violence
against journalists